he has written a book it's called Walk
This Way DMC Aerosmith and the song that
changed American music forever online or
wherever books are sold as we make way
for the Washington Post national arts
reporter and the author of Walk This Way
Geoff edgers who joins us on the program
yeah I stumbled upon a the Rolling Stone
podcast and Jeff's there and he's
passionate telling me yeah glad you
could join me you don't need your
headphones I don't you can hear me here
I the premise of the book is you're
saying that this song where you would
not think that these two parties would
get together to do this at the time that
they did it why did it how did it change
radio well and you know some very
smartypants first that the New York
Times referenced the book and and the
title and and described it as hyperbole
a little bit but it actually is almost
science how this changed everything and
I could tell you in 30 seconds before
Walk This Way the Run DMC version
there was no yo MTV raps in living color
Arsenio Fresh Prince of bel-air and I
found in the archives at Cornell an
attempt in 1985 by Run DMC's publicist
to get them on the Letterman Show and
Letterman's people wrote back and said
sorry doesn't fit the format just a
couple years later you see Paul Shaffer
premiering his solo record with Dion
Carole King and Will Smith on the
microphone so I I mean that's my that's
my elevator pitch but I've got the
reporting to back it up it is science
you know how did it come together these
two bands get together and record this
well you've got Run DMC which was the
most successful rap group of the time
but still not like starship
they weren't mainstream no did you like
start so you got Run DMC and they're
being produced by Rick Rubin who was not
the Rick Rubin we know of now he was not
a very famous man he did have a slightly
bad beard and he ate a lot of Chinese
food but he was not Rick Rubin
yet and then you've got Aerosmith on the
other side and right now they just
opened their Las Vegas run the 50th
anniversary but what we forget but I
don't forget cuz I'm from Boston and I
was 15 then is they were as low as you
could get they had just gotten back
together again but they were still on
drugs they'd put out this record done
with mirrors which I loved but it was a
bomb and the record company basically
said hey come on in here do this thing
here's a thousand bucks so eight
thousand dollars is what got into New
York in March in 1986 which band needed
it most at the time though
well I'd argue Aerosmith only because in
the mythology this whole thing Aerosmith
has been seen as like the the white
knights really riding in and saving this
young rap group when in fact Run DMC was
on the ascension they had already had
hits and Aerosmith was really in
terrible terrible shape and when you
look at what happened afterward
Aerosmith then starts doing things like
dude looks like a lady in permanent
vacation and all those records that made
them more popular than before but at
that point they were in trouble was
their mutual respect when they
collaborated no there was not that is
another piece of the myth and what I
found from my reporting and I reported I
mean I talked to a hundred people for
this thing back in the day people like
to pretend everybody loved each other
you know what I mean like you and I we
have a terrible rivalry and hatred but
we're being friendly here and that's
kind of what happened there the
difference is I found about 20 minutes
of archival footage in the Viacom vaults
which nobody had seen or some editor had
seen didn't cut it down to 90 seconds in
86 and you can see Run DMC and Aerosmith
talking to each other and they have no
idea really what they each do I mean Run
DMC didn't even know the song was called
Walk This Way they just knew the beat to
them was number four on Toys in the
Attic so they would sample this they the
beginning part of Aerosmith's walked
this way yes they didn't get to the
lyrics no they hated the lyrics look I
mean I didn't understand the lyrics no
and who does
I still don't but they're they're very
rap like but what they knew is boom
boo-boom Boosh
they knew that and if you look on
YouTube which I do endlessly you can
find Grandmaster Flash the pioneering DJ
using that sample in 1978 but if you're
a DJ back then if you got to the guitar
and God forbid if you got to the vocal
you were a terrible DJ who would never
be seen again but then what happens to
Run DMC after this song hits
well Run DMC you know is it the song or
is it just their own sort of problems
but basically this is the most
successful thing they'll ever do they
had sold millions of records in the past
but they sold like tens of millions you
know that's huge but what ends up
happening is you know one they start
feuding with the record company and they
sue them and that puts them on the
sidelines for two years in two years in
hip hop in 1986 is an eternity so by the
time they come back with tougher than
leather in 1988 they're already on the
way down I still think it's a good
record but it doesn't sell as well and
then eventually they just kind of fizzle
out Aerosmith on the other hand they
clean up I mean I have this great nitty
gritty I love reporting this great nitty
gritty thing where they actually clean
up because of walk this way because the
management of ariseth had to get tyler
into a drug rehab facility and they had
to do an intervention before the morning
got on too long and they told him that
the BBC wanted to talk to him about Walk
This Way and because of the time change
he needed to be at the offices super
early and so he shows up and he's like
who are all who are all you people and
that like actually cleans them up to
come back if the collaboration doesn't
happen finish that sentence well on the
good side we probably don't have the fat
boys and the beach boys doing wipeout or
limp Biskit right but I also don't know
if we have Public Enemy getting as much
you know getting on Senate Live so you
know and and I was powerful stuff NWA
yeah Tribe Called Quest I don't know if
that stuff is in the mainstream cuz you
might know that radio people
believe it or not they kind of follow
the leader and what happened is this
song was played on mainstream rock radio
was the first rap song that was played
WB CN n Boston played it first and then
everybody else followed and without that
I mean would it if wouldn't eventually
would it have happened it had to right
yeah but I don't know when best to
interview in the book was with who best
interview I mean best snippet might have
been Grandmaster Flash telling me that
he could tell which records would work
as a sample by holding the vinyl up to
the light and seeing how narrow the
groups were oh my god I don't even
understand that but it sounds amazing
right but you know the other thing my
guilty pleasure as an Aerosmith
obsessive as a kid who saw them in 1984
13 on their back in the saddle tour they
weren't really back in the saddle
there's this period from 79 to 85 that's
missing in many histories and they put
out a record Joe Perry went out on tour
I talked to everybody you could find and
I built that nitty-gritty I mean you've
got Tyler and Perry at their lowest
point but still trying to make something
but you've got all this you know there's
an amazing story there that gets them
there I mean the night before they
recorded that song they were playing
this concert with Ted Nugent opening up
I mean that's something to me first
concert I saw was Aerosmith oh really
okay yeah and in Dayton hair Arena what
years that I think it's a 73 74
something like that yeah that's a I mean
that would have you shown yeah I also
saw Joe Perry at Bogart's in Cincinnati
with his solo project
he played down there as well and you
know Bogaerts was a small little concert
venue so early 80s yeah yeah yeah I'm
never seeing Joe Perry there so I've
grown up on Aerosmith and have great
appreciation for Aerosmith but there are
times when you know that they got it and
then there are other times when you go
these guys are on drugs and so you know
the the stones wrote Exile Main Street
or performed Exile on Main Street on
drugs and the Beatles did all this you
know great stuff on drugs I don't know
if Aerosmith was great on drugs or not
but in their minds they probably thought
you got to get on drugs
put out great music here they were
probably high when they collaborated
with Run DMC oh they were let me tell
you but I mean the reality is there's a
point in all these careers I mean you
hear with Joe Walsh after he cleaned up
he couldn't play for a while because he
was terrified of playing playing sober
but there's a point in the 70s like
rocks and toys pneumatic and all that
stuff where the drugs and the chaos and
all that stuff seems to work and then
there's a certain point where it comes
to a grinding halt you know draw the
line and not in the right that's when
that's when it falls apart and you know
if I'm a record producer I just try to
keep the drugs flowing until that moment
and then I run you know did you get any
response from these bands did anybody
get upset with anything reported in this
book it is unclear at a certain point
Aerosmith's management you know said I
love you no copies of the book and so I
sent five copies to them but I've heard
nothing I mean Steven Tyler has my
number and while I was reporting the
book he would hear of something I had
talked to somebody else about I mean I
was in a fabric store with my children I
don't know if you spend a lot of time
fabric stores they're not places where
you do a lot of talking on the phone and
I got this call unknown number and it
was just a guy screaming at me and he
sounded like Buster Poindexter or
something you know and it was Tyler
because he felt like I had said I had
asked someone a question that he found
to be offensive which is that Joe Perry
and Brad Whitford the guitar sanera
Smith when they were starting out were
not judged to be good enough to play
lead on some of the songs and their
producer had brought in guitarist to
play for them Tyler was very offended by
that and he let me know and I just said
Steve and I of all the things I'm in a
fabric store can I call you back and and
and run indie you know Darrell actually
texted me this morning and said I'm just
back from Germany I haven't read the
book but I'm gonna read it I have not
heard from the Reverend run but Chuck D
just tweeted an amazing picture with the
book which is almost worth writing a
book itself the book has walked this way
Run DMC Aerosmith and the song that
changed American music forever and the
author is Geoff edgers from the
Washington Post yeah it was fast
listen because I love you know the
passion yet you had behind this and I'm
thinking all right you got me this
changed radio maybe it's hyperbole but
it was a collaboration when I one
comfortable watching the video when they
collaborate why what is it it doesn't
look like they're they're comfortable
because they're not but I and that's
when I when I saw the book title and I
heard you I went can I go back to that
video and that that really illuminates
what I was watching that they didn't
know each other I don't know if they
respected each other but it felt like
they needed each other for whatever this
was going to be and who takes credit for
the beginning part of walk this way you
mean the drum BS well I have an entire
this shows you how dysfunctional and
functional Aerosmith is at the same time
I have an entire chapter on who created
the beat and I do not come to a
conclusion now you would think the
drummer would get credit Joey Kraemer
but Stephen Tyler who's a drummer at
heart used to drum in the 60s he says he
did it he remembers doing it in 1974 in
Hawaii while Joey Kraemer remembers
creating that in Framingham
Massachusetts a little bit after that
not yeah I mean if you're still willing
to fight about the beat that long after
it occurred it's amazing to see that's
the kind of weirdo nitty gritty that I
love discovering you know and in it then
it takes away the doubt of why would
these guys ever fight with each other if
they're fighting over something like
that like just the minutia I can't
imagine what it would be like being
around Stephen Tyler all the time yeah
you know I met him in Boston and I will
say that I expected this sort of crazy
man and he was incredibly warm and
connective and he was just very very
conscious of his image and his place in
the world you know and so I'm very
curious about when that call comes to me
because he's gonna call and I don't know
if he's gonna be yelling or he's gonna
be praising because it's not an
authorized book but it's got everybody
in it so it's very honest but I hope
they'll respect that you know it's a
road to how they got there and has to
have you know the warts to
pick up the book it's in bookstores
wherever books are sold walk this way
Run DMC Aerosmith in the song that
changed American music forever Jeff
thank you for coming and great to talk
to you thanks for having me launch it
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]